Hi there, I'd like to show you a little feature that we've added to Burp Suite.
Sometimes the small features are the best ones and I think this one's great.
So Burp can now render non-printing characters in the HTTP message editor.
So what this means is for byte values with a hex code of below 20 which is a space, Burp
can now render these as lozenges, showing you the code for the character instead of just
making them invisible.
This is useful for all kinds of purposes.
So you might be playing with an HTTP request smuggling vulnerability and you might want
to use non-standard bytes to confuse the server's parsing.
Or you might place a null byte into a string that's going to be processed by a native code
component if you've got a payload and you want to disrupt something that's filtering
that.
If you're looking at responses you might be looking for an open redirection vulnerability
or an HTTP header injection vulnerability and here you'd be paying close attention to the
line endings characters to see if you can manipulate those.
You might be looking say for a username enumeration bug, sometimes there are really subtle differences
in the application's responses that are only visible in the byte values as opposed to just
eyeballing the raw hex characters.
All sorts of interesting use cases this would be useful for.
This behaviour is off by default and you can easily turn it on and off with a toggle button.
For the moment it's for display only.
You can still manipulate byte values if you go to the hex view in Burp.
Soon we will add the capability to manipulate the byte values directly within the raw view
with the lozenges which will make it a bit easier.
Anyway, that's it.
Hope you have fun, hope you enjoy it.
As always do let us know if you have any feedback.
Thank you.